biden's press conference did you guys
have a chance to listen to biden's
press conference some of it i confess i
didn't dive in deep
so you know from what you heard you know
the topics that they had you know i'll
go to page six so part of it was
his re-election uh uh i watched the
whole thing and it was pretty
interesting seeing what was said because
there was one side that they said he was
horrible and there was one side that
said he this the greatest
maybe the goat of president from what he
did so biden intends to run for
reelection president biden the oldest
person to be sworn into office 78 years
old said he
intends to run for re-election ask the
vice president kamala harris will be on
the ticket he said i would fully expect
that to be the case
she's doing a great job she's a great
partner biden said former president
donald trump has filed for re-election
uh uh early in his presidency uh
had filed for re-election not has filed
for re-election had filed for
re-election early in his presidency
because he needed to biden also said oh
god i miss him with a laugh
asked if he expected to run against
donald trump was 74 years old biden said
oh come on i don't even think about that
i have no idea
biden then blamed trump for all the uh
border issues which will
uh he got into you know pretty
aggressively i think
most the covet topic lasted
two minutes of the entire thing meaning
media
is not even worried about the covet
situation you have to know that media
only asks whatever area you have
problems with
so if the media didn't ask any questions
about covet that means they're over it
listen it's good we're going back 100
million 200 million
you know but but they spend a lot of
time on immigration
okay under pressure over the flow of
immigrants migrants of the southern
border
biden took aim at his predecessor saying
that the president trump eliminated
funding and
resources for the border biden said what
we're doing now is attempting to rebuild
we're building
up the capacity that should have been
maintained and built upon and trump
dismantled it it's going to take time
unaccompanied miners are crossing
illegally each day in record numbers
with total
uh crossing this year on pace to hit a
two-decade high
facing growing bipartisan pressure the
administration is ramping up its
diplomatic efforts and racing to find
more shelter space to house children as
it tries to tackle
surge of asylum seekers without adopting
the aggressive deterrent strategies of
previous administration so
you know couple things were asked which
was interesting he said we're about to
put
5000 beds in fort bliss
for people the migrant kids that are
coming here people are coming here from
texas
and then the question was asked by uh uh
uh
one two ladies one lady says look you
know
your campaign was around how noble of a
man you are and how amazing of a man you
are
and do you think more immigrants are
coming to america
because they're seeing you be more
reasonable
and so they're wanting to come to
america versus when trump was here they
felt like they're going to send their
kids back
so they didn't send their kids do you
see a spike in more parents
wanting to send their kids here because
you're not sending them back okay
and his his response was interesting he
said
he said no i don't see any difference
there he says and if it was because i'm
nice i don't think people are sending
their kids more here because i'm nice
this is an issue that's been going on
for quite some time and it's not
something that i have any issues with
then another lady asked the question
said
a lady from honduras sent her a son
nine-year-old son
to come and cross the border because she
felt
you again wouldn't send him send him
back
you would let him come to america uh and
that message is coming across where more
parents are
taking their savings and they're given
to coyote to bring the kids to america
and he says no i'm not that's not the
case either
you know if they do come we're gonna do
our best and another person asked and
said
well how come we can't see anything can
we see what's going on and
what's the plan down there he says i
don't intend to go down there myself
because i don't want the attention to be
taken off what the people are doing
i don't want to go there with secret
service which you know trump would have
been there in a heartbeat and so would
have obama so what if other people
would have been their heartbeat and he
says i'm not intending on going out
there i'm going to send my troops my
people to go out there and see what's
going on and come back
ted cruz gets on and he gives a speech
he says
never has there been a president not
obama not
trump not clinton not bush who didn't
allow media to go to the borders to see
how these kids
are being treated there's a big uh you
know
uh spread of covet right now going on so
biden's
using that as an uh as a way of saying
well we don't want people to go out
there because there's a big outbreak we
don't want a lot of the media to get
covered
so we're trying to protect you anyways
there was a lot of different things that
was talked about but they were hitting
them
you know hitting them very strongly on
the immigration part
tom do you have any thoughts on the
how immigration is being you know the
borders being handled right now with
biden versus how it was handled prior to
him with trump
yeah yeah i think it's early in his
presidency his policies haven't really
been fully implemented
and the last thing he wants is a board
media down there
finding an angle and i don't think
there's much change that's gone down on
there
you know there hasn't been time to and
so he doesn't want the
media to go down there because now any
kids remember the terrible thing we
would see kids in basically
not little small detention apartments or
holding things but they look like cages
it was terrible
um it was terrible and it started under
previous president
i don't think he wants anybody down
there you know taking pictures because
this is now his problem you're the
president
so even if you didn't start it it
becomes your problem and you gotta
fix it you gotta finish it oh that's
what the sound is this entire time i've
been thinking it's the mic it's the way
tom's speaking
that's what you're doing i'm calling
these guys out there like i'm telling
you it's not the mic
it's time okay all right so i'm relieved
tom thank you for that
that that that two-second f kind of
thank you thank you for distraction so
we'll go back to what i said i don't
think biden wants him down there taking
pictures and doing things because now
he's the president so he has to bring
the solution
they'll put it on him that's not what he
what do you think about him you know i'm
from the perspective of my friend craig
sawman sawyer who's a former navy seal
and he's there at the border all day
he's seen a huge spike
in people jumping aboard a huge spike
and sadly a huge since his big thing too
is also
preventing human trafficking huge spike
in human trafficking too as well
so so it's it's it's it's more now than
it was during when when trump
was controlling the border 100 he's
saying it's more now than more now than
it was
why do you think that is well you know
there's there's a lot of factors going
into you know
and again i'm again from my perspective
of what my family had to do to get here
from the philippines it was it was a
it was a recruitment into the nursing
program for my mother to get here
to say i'm going to be a nurse to be
recruited into the united states
and then our other family members
there's a five-year waiting period
10-year waiting period
for them to get here to the united
states from the philippines versus
people just come here to the border
and because of these uh these loosened
uh
policies to say hey we just come here
we'll campaign we'll get
we'll get across we'll get across to
find a way to get in here kind of bully
the way and kick down
kick down the the gate kick down the
door um you know i i don't know why it's
it's it's
getting to that point but uh there's a
huge influx of that you know from from a
practicality standpoint
which would become biden's problem
because now he's the guy in the chair
blame your predecessor blame whoever you
want but now you're the guy in chair you
got to fix it right yep
yep you know again this is
uh this is not going to go away meaning
i don't think
even the liberal media is going to let
them go with this without holding them
accountable to it because
there are a lot of people in the liberal
media who are latinos and latinos who
are going to want to be
seeing what's going on because their
loyalty is to their community and if
they don't ask those questions about
what's going on with their community
their own people going to be like how
come you're not
holding the president accountable i
think that's a great point i think it's
a great point what do you think it took
so long i'm sorry tom
no i think that the you know the the
media is not in lockstep
with biden they really wanted him
elected but they're not in lockstep with
him there's a civil war inside
you don't think so no way i think
there's a civil war inside the
democratic party with bernie over here
and i also think there's a civil war
that's going on inside the media
between the people that are being told
to be lap dogs and be nice and the
people that have got
strong viewpoints and they want to see
change such as
i have deep respect versus people of
hispanic descent that are in the media
they're they're speaking up
and want to see change want to see great
benefits come to these issues
and don't just want to be a lap dog on a
political party basis i have deep
respect for them and they're going to
speak up and they're going to make the
stories out of it
what do you think it took uh biden this
long to get an official press conference
you know you know the whole thing with
uh
he doesn't know how to handle himself in
public when they ask him questions there
was a couple times where you kind of
like
that was that was very weird he was
going and he's like
yeah so here's am i talking too much
and then lady helped him he's like let
me just ask my second question yeah
okay okay go ahead go ahead so that was
a little awkward i don't know if you
guys caught that or not
very very awkward another part was uh do
i need to go into more detail yeah i'll
just stop right now
yeah that was a little awkward and then
there was another part where
uh uh he was going off the co like one
time he just read what was on the card
he just went like this he's like so what
what i think we need to do
is he looked down for 30 seconds just
reading the card to answer the question
okay
but then there was another part where
he went speaking for 10 minutes and it
wasn't based off of a
card i was like that seemed reasonable
what he just said right there i
actually was tracking with him and he
was given stats and data and numbers and
here's what happened here so so i don't
think
he is where most people think he is i
don't think he is where most people
think he is where he is
you know uh uh what's the word they use
where
uh you know he can't remember he's
coherent
not coherent there's another ward but
cogent and lucid
yeah so so i don't know if it's those
words that's a level above me with words
but uh
but i would say at a point where he can
process issues and communicate with
people now
why do i think he's not done a press
conference for a while
uh you know i just don't it's like
why does somebody play defense and make
a player go left because they
don't do well going left right you don't
do a dribbling to the left so
you as the offensive player have to
figure out a way to get what to the area
of strength which is to the right
his strength is not public speaking at
all joe biden
i don't know how many trophies he won
public speaking it's not his strength
it's definitely not so if that's not the
case you just have to have other people
doing the talking form and
not being him that's my thoughts so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye